people today should really understand
that the ocean underpins everything that
people care about if you like to breathe
you'll listen up because most of the
oxygen in the atmosphere is generated
out there in the ocean the ocean shapes
temperature climate weather
it's where most of the water is and all
life people very much included need
water so when rain falls out of the sky
doesn't matter where on the planet you
are the ocean is touching with you they
should also know that just in a
relatively short period of time my
lifetime more change has taken place in
the ocean than during all preceding
human history changes some of them good
I mean we've learned more about the
ocean since the middle of the 20th
century during all preceding history we
have technology that enables us to get
high in the sky and look at the whole
world and see that it's mostly blue we
can dive deep into the sea James Cameron
National Geographic
explorer-in-residence filmmaker many
things it was one of three people only
three who have ever been to the deepest
part of the ocean and it's only seven
miles down but at least we have the
technology that makes that possible
for the first time in history access to
the ocean is now as never before a
reality we can go high in the sky but
we're still a little behind the curve in
terms of exploring this part of the
universe earth Earth's ocean we need to
know that the ocean was in trouble and
that there are things that can be done
now to reverse the decline of coral
reefs about half of them since I began
exploring the ocean in the 1950s I have
either disappeared or they're in a state
of serious decline 90% of many of the
fish are gone they didn't just evaporate
we've eaten them
and we've we've also through the methods
used for capturing fish to take to
market have caused some real problems
like clear cutting forests we've
clear-cut the ocean and left whole
ecosystems in disarray 50 years ago we
thought there's nothing that we could do
to harm the ocean the ocean is so big so
vast so resilient
it was thought that the ocean is simply
too big to fail and a lot of people
still think that and that has to change
because the ocean is big and vast and
resilient as it is it's not infinitely
so we only have a little bit left to
restore what has been lost
[Music]